hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I o
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well approaching the
admin of his early great work the modal
ogion after arguing that the rational
creature was created in order to love
the supreme good that is love God and
some argues that we're going one of two
places eventually either towards eternal
happiness or beatitude or towards its
opposite eternal misery or unhappiness
and he talks about this in terms of
Plenty and poverty this is actually a
theme that ansem developed at great
length and in some of his later works
and distinguished the parts of happiness
and misery we're not going to go into
that too much sure we're interested in
the structure of his argumentation about
this how are we going to arrive at the
point where you're either getting one or
the other so he starts out being in
chapter 69 by talking about the
happiness end of it and he says that the
human creature was made to love the
supreme essence without an end and he
has an argument that he provides for
that here what
what is that argument well he says that
here we go it must have been made in
order that would love the the supreme
essence since it must have been made
either in order that it might love
without end or that it might add
sometimes lose this love whether
willingly by force those are the two
options so the question is Kim it lose
this love for the Supreme essence and
you might say well why couldn't it I
mean people lose their face all the time
they say that they love God and then
they do other things ansel himself in
his prayers and it you know other other
discussions says that he himself as a
sinner and as you know departed from
from the love of God soap so why
couldn't we actually do that so handsome
says it's not the case that the supreme
wisdom would make the rational being in
order that it might at some time either
disdain so greater good or lose it by
force even even though it wills to hold
on to it so so long as the preacher does
indeed will to love to continue to love
the divine good that's not going to be
taken away from it and he says that
means that it's going to have to live
forever because otherwise it would have
this love at some time taken away from
it right but while all of its being is
taken away from it if it were to cease
to exist and that would not be just the
Supreme Being would not create us in
such a fashion where that actually one
is a live possibility certainly
something we can imagine but Anselm is
ruling it out as a live possibility so
this is going to be eternal life as he
says the only remaining possibilities
that made in order to might love the
supreme essence without em it's been
made in such a way that it will always
live always wheels too
do what it was made for so long as the
creature continues to love God and
presumably ask you know in heaven or
something like that the creature is just
going to continue to love God so he says
I'm going out a little bit further what
sort of life will it have after all what
good is a wildlife unless it is truly
secure against the onslaught of troubles
remember this is somebody writing by the
way in the 11th century time when
trouble is it that you know they had are
things that we've sort of take for
granted is not being a big deal so
Anselm is very cognizant to this he says
if someone as if someone as long as he
lives a subject to troubles that either
fears or suffers or else is deceived by
a false security is his life not
miserable so you know the human creature
by loving God is not going to be made
miserable in this you know living
forever rather the human creature is
going to possess things securely he says
it's utterly absurd any nature always
leads a miserable life but always loving
him who is supremely good and omnipotent
that doesn't really make sense loving
the supreme good is not going to make us
miserable and this is an interesting
thing to seem to people who seem to have
you know very duty-bound conception we
gotta love the Supreme Being or God or
whatever it is and their lives are
miserable there must be something out of
joint there he would say so he says is
therefore clearly human soul is such
that if it preserves what it was made
for so long as it continues to love God
that is to continue to know God
understand God remember God it will at
some time live happily truly secure from
death itself and all the other troubles
and in Chapter seven me he flushes this
out of it what is this going to be like
so he starts
asking is the supreme essence going to
give any sort of reward or recompense to
the rational creature who loves it then
again he thinks about what would it make
sense to do does it make sense that it
would just say oh nice that you love me
don't really care not a big deal for me
I'm supreme essence of course you know
so you loving me doesn't doesn't provide
me with anything well you know we know
that God is infinitely just God is
Supreme justice itself so it wouldn't
really make sense I mean a human being
somebody does them a good turn they
ought to do them a good turn it doesn't
make sense to say that God wouldn't do
that so he says here we go if he gives
no reward to one who loves him he who is
most just doesn't distinguish doesn't
distinguish what doesn't distinguish
between one who loves what he ought to
be supremely loved and wanted who
disdains or contends it one who pushes
it away nor does he love one who loves
him either that where it does no good to
be loved by him and he says these things
are incompatible with the divine nature
so the divine nature must give some sort
of reward to the person who loves the
divine nature now the question is okay
so what kind of reward would that be I
mean is it having this this eternal life
that sounds pretty good doesn't it is it
a life of eternal beatitude you know
being free from pain or sickness or
disappointment all these sorts of things
that Devil us in this life well it's
something even better than that
according to an some as a matter of fact
this is almost you know exceeding the
the notion of like giving that so that
you get something in return because what
the human being gets in loving the
divine essence is so much greater than
whatever it is a human being can
contribute so he says what does he give
us a reward if you gave a rational
essence to nothing in order
might love him what will he give to
someone who does love him if he does not
cease to love he says what will the
benefit of love be like for the rational
creature is the rational creature which
is useless to itself without the this
love is so eminent and eminent among all
creatures nothing can be the reward of
this long except that which is super
eminent above all nature's something
which is greater than the rational being
well one could that be well as it turns
out that is going to be the supreme good
what is greatest among all nature's what
a super evident God God Himself God
gives God as the reward for love you
might say that that doesn't sound like
such a great of a war well Ansem goes on
to explain why I would then be such a
great reward he says who loves justice
truth happiness and incorruptible ax t
in such a way that he was not into the
desire to enjoy them God is justice
itself just you know if we only take one
of the divine attributes so what that
means is loving justice now just in the
forms that we see it here but loving
justice in itself means that the reward
for that is that justice itself gives
itself to you the lover to enjoy and we
can say similarly for everything else
wisdom rationality life itself
simplicity all of these things are given
not by God but as God you could say so
he says what will the supreme goodness
give us a reward who love to the one who
loves and desires him it is not himself
anything else he might give would not be
a reward since it would not recommend
salone or console' the one who loves him
or satisfy the one who desires him
either the effort if he wills to be
locked in desired so he might give
something else as a reward he does not
will to be loved and desired for
don't say but for the sake of something
else God wants living human beings
rational human beings to desire God as
the greatest good so that God can in
fact give himself hits off whatever we
want to call it to the rational being so
the reward here in this case is you
might say for things to go the way that
they are intended to go for the rational
creature to be essentially connected up
with with God so he goes on and he want
to skip over a little bit he says in
chapter 71 now we get to the bad side
the eternal misery the the going to hell
side right he says it follows that a
soul that disdains the love of the
Supreme could will encourage supreme
misery well one might say that for such
disdain it would be more justly punished
if it lost its very existence or life
and an some considers this this issue is
it better does it make more sense that
the rational creature who disdains and
the word that uses there's contend that
I contend contend edmonds is a
participle contends of supreme good it
incurs eternal misery or does it make
sense that they would lose their
existence altogether and some says it
doesn't really make sense for them to
lose existence altogether because then
they're not really being punished are
they and so you might say well he's got
the sort of punitive model of mine no
it's really about justice it's really
about God being God and the rest of
creation being the rest of creation so
he says that certainly before such a
creature exists that it could neither be
a fault or experienced punishment but of
a soul that disdained what it was made
for dies so that it experiences nothing
there is nothing at all it will be in
the same state both when it is most
greatly at fault and when it
without any fault so he says nor with
the supremely wise justice then
distinguished between what is capable of
no good and Will's no evil that is the
non-existent creature and what it is
capable of the greatest good and yet at
the same time Will's the greatest evil
that has turns away against God turns
after some other created goods that are
lesser goods um Anselm is saying here
that it would not be justice on God's
part not to punish it's not that God as
vindictive and you know if you're not
going to play by my rules I'm going to
screw you over or something like that
it's rather that the creature by you
know choosing the wrong things is going
to bring upon itself what has to be that
case you know the real what the
creatures being deprived of is in
essence God the reward that the lover of
God is is receiving so he goes on and he
says it's quite obvious then you know
this has to be the case nothing could
seem more logical nothing should be
believed more certainly than this the
human soul was made in such a way that
if it disdains to love the supreme
essence it will suffer eternal misery
just as one who loves him will rejoice
in an eternal reward when a disdains it
will suffer under an eternal punishment
and just as the former will experience
immutable plenty the latter will
experience inconsolable poverty things
will be bad for it in every way you
might say conceivable or possible so
Anselm is saying for the rational
creature there's no opt-out there's
there's ultimately one way or the other
way and one way is the greatest reward
possible the other way is the greatest
penalty possible no there's other issues
that could be raised at this point that
you know go beyond it is like well why'd
it might somebody you know choose to do
things wrong in this case Ansel
discuss that at plenty of other issues
in other text and he also does want to
stress this is later on in the Moto G
Anselm says look we can't really know
who is getting what with any degree of
certainty because we're not actually got
we can have some guidelines if you're
going around he doesn't say this but
here's an example you're going around
stabbing everybody just you know
stabbing stabbing stabbing stabbing
you're probably getting the internal
misery because that's incompatible with
a loving God right but there's it could
be all sorts of people who you know
think that they're going to eternal
happiness that aren't going there
they're going to be some people who
think that they deserve eternal misery
and they will be saved and made good in
the am a worthy of doing that may be
made able to love the divine good of
their vitae to participate so he's not
saying that we can know who actually
fits in one side of the other what are
you saying look there's two categories
and you you're going to pick one of them
depending on whether you love the
supreme good as the supreme good or
whether you reject it whether you
content whether you disdain it whether
you choose something else in its place